[Música]
realmente hablar de revista de prensa en
directo américa de france 24 hoy lunes
iniciando una nueva semana rosa pérez
más de cómo le fue el fin de semana así
descanso para esta nueva semana
informativa en director y co más amenas
buena rosas vamos con todo entonces y
abrimos esta revista de prensa con lo
que sucedió en melilla uno de los dos
enclaves españoles fronterizos con
marruecos donde españa ha levantado las
vallas para así delimitar la frontera
europa africana y donde financia la
actuación de la policía marroquí para
que reprima los migrantes de su lado de
la frontera rosa distintos medios
también condenan esta operación policial
español marroquí que causó 37 muertos 37
muertos entre perdieron la vida con esto
no además contienen las palabras del
presidente del gobierno español pedro
sánchez que elogió la actuación de las
autoridades a pesar de que hubo como ya
lo dijimos 37 muertos empezamos con
editorial del país
exactamente drawn la cuestión es que el
país se titula este suceso con su
editorial fronteras de muerte y es que
no se puede entender pues este episodio
esta matanza sin recordar un poco lo que
suponen los enclaves de ceuta y melilla
y es que como aquí nos queda muy alejado
no sé si no está de más hacer un pequeño
apunte y es que recordemos que ceuta y
melilla son dos ciudades españolas por
lo tanto territorio europeo que están en
el norte de áfrica particularmente
haciendo frontera directa terrestre con
marruecos no y delimitando estas dos
ciudades ceuta y melilla pues se
levantan altos muros financiados por
españa y por la unión europea y que
además implican acuerdos con las
autoridades marroquíes para que la
policía de marruecos vigile controle su
lado de la frontera pero digamos que
marruecos no tiene un especial interés
en controlar esa frontera porque las
personas que la quieren atravesar
quieren salir de su territorio y entrar
en el territorio español o europeo no la
policía marroquí controla estas
fronteras a cambio de contrapartidas
ofrecidas tanto por la unión europea
como por parte de españa ya sean pues a
sumas millonarias de euros o por ejemplo
lo que sucedió reciente y lo que todos
los analistas y medios están
relacionando con este episodio que fue
el reconocimiento por parte de españa
del plan marroquí para el sáhara
occidental' bien en este marco ayer bye
perdón ayer esté la noche de este
viernes a este sábado la policía
marroquí reprimió a más de 1000 personas
que querían entrar el territorio español
y según distintas organizaciones
distintas ong como caminando fronteras
el número de fallecidos a causa de esta
operación fueron 37 mientras que
marruecos de momento
pues cifra en 23 los muertos en el país
lo que dice es que los acuerdos entre
españa y marruecos entre la unión
europea y marruecos deberían sea como
sea respetar los derechos humanos algo
que pues como decíamos es evidente que
no sucede ni habitualmente ni todavía
menos pues este viernes dice en lo que
sucedió fue el episodio más cruento y
con mayor número de víctimas y un
episodio que sin embargo sánchez el
presidente del gobierno español pedro
sánchez elogió dice además la situación
no dejará de repetirse entre otras cosas
porque
circunstancias hechos como el cambio
climático o la escasez de granos ha
debido a la guerra de ucrania provocarán
cada vez mayores flujos migratorios del
sur hacia el norte global claro me es
evidente que la ley se tiene que
respetar pero pues no hacerlas respetar
de esa manera rosa la posición del medio
contexto si dice el contexto no hay duda
acerca de la inhumanidad el desprecio
por la vida y la complicidad de las
respectivas fuerzas de seguridad ni ni
de su responsabilidad criminal cita
califica las imágenes de un matadero o
un lãder nazi dice las cifras de muertos
son escandalosas pero no menos que las
declaraciones del presidente del
gobierno pedro sánchez que como decíamos
elogió la policía marroquí consideró su
actuación de extraordinaria y calificó
pues la situación de bien resuelta no
dio ni una palabra sobre las víctimas
sus familias ni la menor alusión a una
investigación ni una sombra de luto por
la pérdida de vidas humanas y es que
tanto marruecos como españa quiere
enterrar los cuerpos de las personas
fallecidas sin autopsia ni investigación
y identificación dice por otro lado que
españa y marruecos están pagando a
sicarios perdón a españa y la unión
europea pagan a sicarios como es el caso
de marruecos para matar a las personas
que ellos no se atreven a matar y dice
nunca mataremos lo suficiente para que
los humanos dejen de huir de su país y
entren al nuestro a españa ni para que
la extrema derecha no llegue al poder y
es que una de las críticas que se está
haciendo al gobierno socialista es que
está comprando completamente pues el
discurso de la extrema derecha
en el mismo sentido la periodista olga
rodríguez se escribe en el diario punto
es no en mi nombre
exactamente dice no en nuestro nombre en
el nombre pues de los españoles o de los
europeos que al final como decíamos
somos los que pedimos y los que
financiamos a países como marruecos para
que tenga este tipo de política de
control de la frontera olga rodríguez
dice que pedro sánchez está empleando el
marco de la extrema derecha como decimos
cuando habla y cuando alaba la actuación
policial marroquí y además dice y
pedro sánchez el sábado digamos que
culpó a las mafias del tráfico de
personas de el asalto masivo porque se
refirió en estos términos pues a la
frontera española y dice digamos que
culpar a las mafias de tráfico de
personas es como si las personas que
intentan llegar a europa carecieran de
voluntad propia y migrarán obligadas
como si no hubieran graves problemas en
los lugares de origen que empujan a
muchos seres humanos a buscar otros
rumbos como si no hubiera guerras
violencias pobreza saqueos de recursos
sequías crisis climática y hambre de las
que muchas pues tiene responsabilidad el
norte global dice box y sus aliados
europeos ya están ganando sin haber
conquistado las urnas rosa como siempre
muchísimas gracias a por toda la
información de esta revista de prensa
del lunes nos vemos mañana con más
pasamos a saludar a nuestra primera
invitada al día